nos dicen al cuadrilátero a bs dem se le
aplica una mudez ya cuyo centro es el
punto p así que aquí tenemos el
cuadrilátero y se le va a aplicar una
potencia usando como centro el punto p
después nos hacen varias preguntas las
coordenadas de los vértices se conservan
los nuevos segmentos siguen en la misma
recta las medidas de los ángulos se
conservan y las longitudes de los lados
el perímetro y el área se conservan la
idea de este vídeo es ver que se
conserva y que no después de aplicar una
potencia así que pausa el vídeo e
intenta responder las preguntas ahora
trabajemos en las respuestas una de las
primeras cosas que pudiste haber notado
es que nos dicen que se aplicará una
potencia pero no nos dicen cuál es la
razón de potencia que aplicaremos
sabemos que el centro es el punto p pero
cuál es la razón de potencia no nos la
dicen y esto es porque las preguntas
pueden aplicarse a cualquier razón de
potencia
pero para ayudarnos a visualizar el
problema qué tal si aplicamos una razón
de motes
por aquí digamos que nuestra razón de
potencia es de un médium para que quepa
en esta página cómo se va a ver el
cuadrilátero bueno si el punto am está a
una distancia de 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 del
punto pm la prima estará a una distancia
de 4 porque tenemos una razón de
potencia de un medio así que aquí estará
a prima es decir está en la misma línea
pero a la mitad de distancia el punto de
ésta a 1 2 3 4 5 6 unidades de distancia
del punto p por lo tanto el punto de
prima estarán a 3 unidades a la mitad
del camino entonces este de aquí será el
segmento a prima de prima que
corresponde al segmento atem después de
aplicarle la potencia
ahora veamos el punto b si le aplicamos
una razón de potencia de un medio y está
a una distancia de 1 2 3 4 5 6 de am
ok de prima estarán a tres unidades de a
prima así que por aquí vamos a tener ave
prima por lo tanto puedes ver que prima
también está en la línea que junta ave
con pep pero está a la mitad de
distancia por eso tenemos una razón del
tc de un medio que fue la que elegimos
ahora para obtener al punto sem tenemos
que darnos cuenta de que para llegar al
punto cm bajamos cuatro unidades desde p
y avanzamos dos más hacia la izquierda
por lo tanto el punto se priman va a
estar a la mitad del camino a todos
unidades hacia abajo y a una hacia la
izquierda aquí estará se prima ahora si
este de aquí el cuadrilátero a prima de
prima se prima de prima es la imagen del
cuadrilátero
abc de después de aplicarle la potencia
cuyo centro es el punto p tomando una
razón de potencia arbitraria y la razón
del por qué hice este dibujo es porque
con él será mucho más fácil responder
las preguntas
la primera dicen las coordenadas de los
vértices se conservan pues rápidamente
puedes ver que todos los vértices tienen
coordenadas diferentes por lo tanto
podemos decir no las coordenadas de los
vértices no se conservan segunda los
nuevos segmentos siguen en la misma
recta tampoco puedes ver que los nuevos
segmentos sean paralelos a los
anteriores
avn es paralela a prima b prima además
es paralela a prima de prima etcétera
pero ojo no forzosamente están en la
misma recta 3a las medidas de los
ángulos se conservan si las medidas de
los ángulos se conservan en una potencia
este ángulo tiene la misma medida que
este ángulo este ángulo recto sigue
siendo un ángulo recto este ángulo tiene
la misma medida que este nuevo ángulo y
de igual manera para este último
por lo tanto si las medidas de los
ángulos se conservan y esta información
es importante tenerla en cuenta cuando
hacemos una potencia última pregunta las
longitudes de los lados el perímetro y
el área se conservan bueno las noticias
no son transformaciones rígidas por lo
tanto las longitudes de los lados no se
conservan
es decir la distancia entre los puntos
no se conserva y se ve claramente aquí
si los datos no se conservan tampoco lo
hará el perímetro ni el área así que la
respuesta es no para todas estas
propiedades al aplicar una potencia no
se conservan si habláramos de una
transformación rígida como una rotación
o una traslación esto sí sucedería estas
tres propiedades si se conservarían muy
bien ahora hagamos otro ejemplo
y hagamos este de acá al triángulo abc
se le aplica o no mote se concentró en
el punto c otra vez no nos dice la razón
de modestia pero nos hacen las mismas
cuatro preguntas así que de nuevo pausa
el vídeo e inténtalo por tu cuenta
bien vamos a trabajarlo juntos y de
nuevo voy a aplicar una razón de
potencia de un medio es mi favorita la
razón de montesión es de un médium y de
nuevo voy a aplicar la potencia para que
veas lo que sucede esta vez va a ocurrir
algo interesante ya que tenemos como
centro a uno de los vértices del
triángulo original veamos del punto a al
punto c vamos tres unidades hacia la
izquierda y seis unidades hacia arriba 3
hacia la izquierda y 6 hacia arriba
entonces si aplicamos una razón de
montecillos medium nos vamos a mover una
unidad y media hacia la izquierda y 3
hacia arriba así que acabaremos aquí
este será a prima y observa esta vez si
caemos en el segmento original en el
segmento ac y esto sucede porque tenemos
un vértice como el centro de la potencia
ahora pensemos donde terminarán ven
después de aplicarle la potencia de c a
b vamos 2 hacia la derecha y después
vamos 4 hacia arriba si estamos tomando
una razón de montaje de un medio de
prima tendría que estar aquí una unidad
hacia la derecha de sem y 2 hacia arriba
así que ya está aquí tenemos la imagen
del triángulo y claro se va a dar a c
prima porque son el mismo punto que en
este caso es nuestro centro de murcia de
modo que aquí tenemos esta imagen a
prima de prima sería entonces las
coordenadas de los vértices se conservan
bueno puedo decir que es sólo en sem los
vértices no se conservarán y la única
razón del por qué las coordenadas de
cesc se conservan es porque ese era el
centro de la potencia entonces déjame
ponerlo solo nc los nuevos segmentos
siguen en la misma recta bueno en este
caso a prima se prima están en la misma
recta que hacen
y de manera similar para ver primas e
prima están en la misma recta que en bs
una vez más esto es porque el centro de
la noticia es uno de nuestros vértices
de hecho observa no pasa lo mismo con la
primavera prima no están en la misma
recta es paralela pero no es la misma ok
vamos a la siguiente pregunta las
medidas de los ángulos se conservan no
tenemos que ver esta imagen para
responder que es y como ya dijimos los
ángulos se conservan siempre en una
potencia este ángulo
me dirá lo mismo que este ángulo a prima
ven me dirá lo mismo que me priva se me
dirá lo mismo que se prima y por último
las longitudes de los lados el perímetro
y el área se conservan de nuevo no en
una potencia la longitud de los lados no
se conserva por lo tanto no se conserva
el perímetro ni se conservarán el área
perfecto con esto hemos acabado nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo